[Music]
on this Wednesday night the Prime
Minister goes public with a very private
matter Justin Trudeau and his wife
Sophie are separating how public life
factored into their marriage America's
former vice president weighs in on
Donald Trump the president was
surrounded by a group of crackpot
lawyers and what a co-conspirator
allegedly suggested to stop anti-trump
protesters calling out the Russian
president's lies I cannot be now quiet
Ukraine's Chief Rabbi pushes back on
Russian propaganda and explosive warning
the massive volcanic eruption that could
fuel global warming
yeah
National with Donna Friesen good evening
and thanks for joining us we begin with
personal news about prime minister
Justin Trudeau he and his wife Sophie
Gregoire Trudeau have announced they're
separating they've been married for 18
years she has been by his side
throughout his political career and
they've raised three children together
they've attended countless public events
together including the king's coronation
in London this spring Gregoire Trudeau
broke the news of the separation on
Instagram today saying Justin and I
would like to share the fact that after
many meaningful and difficult
conversations we have made the decision
to separate as always we remain close
family with deep love and respect for
each other and for everything we have
built and will continue to build with me
now is our Ottawa bureau chief Mercedes
Stevenson Mercedes ending a marriage
especially when children are involved is
difficult for anyone when you're in
public office it all happens in the
spotlight what is the prime minister's
office saying about about this well
Donna as you saw the Prime Minister and
Sophie Greg wartruto decided to announce
their separation in a more informal
manner than the traditional press
release of the past posting in near
simultaneous identical messages on
Instagram a formal statement followed
from the prime minister's office that
stated the two have signed quote a legal
separation agreement and taken all
necessary legal and ethical steps both
the separation agreement and the
carefully coordinated co-announcement
are indicators that this was a carefully
planned event going forward the Prime
Minister will continue to reside at
Rideau Hall as will the children Sophie
Gregoire Trudeau will live in an
additional residence but I am told that
she will be present at Rito Cottage
quite regularly and that she will stay
there when the prime minister is away as
well the whole family is going on
vacation together in coming days which
tells you this is amicable and the Prime
Minister and Ms Gregoire Trudeau have
asked for privacy for their children the
focus of course is on protecting them
the Prime Minister has spoken in in the
past about how painful the separation
was for him between his father and
Margaret Trudeau and he will likely be
bearing that in mind now as he makes
decisions Pierre Elliot Trudeau was the
last prime minister to separate while in
office
Mercedes Sophie Gregoire Trudeau has
been by her husband's side since he got
elected they've endured a lot together
will there be any political implications
to this separation well as you said
Donna this was really a political power
couple and Sophie Gregoire Trudeau's
absence will certainly change how he
campaigns it could play politically but
Donna the reality is also that many
Canadians are separated or divorced and
can relate I'm told that the family will
continue to appear together in public so
don't be surprised by seeing that but
Sophie will no longer carry out actual
official duties she has of course been a
key part of Mr Trudeau's political
success but we noticed a marked drop-off
in her Presence at Mr Trudeau's
appearances and her own visibility in
recent months the last time we saw them
together was Canada Day in terms of the
opposition I doubt that the leaders in
those parties would go on the attack
over something so personal so this will
likely be treated as a private event
okay Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa thanks
[Music]
Anyone who puts himself over the
Constitution should never be president
of the United States sadly the president
was surrounded by a group of crackpot
lawyers that kept telling him what his
itching ears wanted to hear
that is former U.S vice president Mike
Pence talking about his former boss's
attempt to overturn the 2020
presidential election the indictment
filed yesterday details the ways Donald
Trump pressured Pence to refuse to
certify the results of that election
Trump is set to appear in court tomorrow
on charges he conspired to cling to
power Jackson prosco on what happens
next we were getting ready to win this
election frankly we did win this one
from the moment he refused to concede
Donald Trump allegedly began a sprawling
campaign to overturn the will of Voters
culminating in a violent attempt to
block the transfer of power you have to
see what happened at the Capitol as kind
of the last most desperate
prong in a multi-part strategy that
strategy is at the heart of the second
Federal indictment against the former
president four counts with one Central
claim that Trump was fully aware he had
lost the election but kept up the
seditious lie I don't think he's an
island at all I think he's the decision
maker but he was supported by a number
of willing co-conspirators the
indictment alleges one of those six
co-conspirators even suggested turning
the American Military on citizens if
protests erupted after Trump clung to
power they are likely to be charged
separately to expedite Trump's trial my
office will seek a speedy trial that our
evidence can be tested in court and
judged by a jury of citizens it's been a
long time coming but in so many ways it
just marks the beginning
police officer Daniel Hodges was
brutally assaulted by Trump's supporters
on January 6 2021
he sees criminal charges against Trump
as necessary accountability what's your
biggest worry about the future
they tried to do on January 6 of the
months prior and they'll do a better job
of it in the future a serious concern
with Trump still a widely supported and
viable contender in the 2024
presidential campaign what do you want
people to remember
that a democracy is only as strong as
the people who participate in it the
indictment suggests that former vice
president Mike Pence was no casual
Observer his notes about Trump's
desperate scheme form the basis for many
of the charges Donna we should also note
that the judge assigned to the case has
a track record of harshly punishing
other January 6th defendants
all right Jackson prosco in Washington
thanks there was a slump on the stock
market today after the ratings giant
Fitch downgraded the U.S government's
AAA credit rating to double A Plus
citing financial and political
instability wall Street's three biggest
stock indices were all down at the close
today it was the nasdaq's worst day
since February sliding more than two
percent well as Canadians deal with the
skyrocketing cost of living it's not
easy to understand what is driving
inflation profits at some corporations
have soared and so-called greed flation
is often considered a cause of rising
costs but new research from the Bank of
Canada is telling a different tale
tariya isri explains
[Applause]
a wave of job action is sweeping across
Canada with Metro workers the latest to
demand their wages match inflation
or as the NDP calls it greed inflation
the big grocery store chains have earned
record profits over the past three years
they're gouging Canadians they're making
more money than ever before while
Canadians can't afford to buy their
groceries so we're seeing enough's
enough
but research by economists at the Bank
of Canada is challenging that argument
and landing in the middle of a thorny
debate a new report has found corporate
profits are not driving up inflation
it's not the first of its kind to find
to look at the same question and to find
the same result everybody seems to find
that prices have more or less gone up in
line with costs economists at the
Central Bank analyzed the financial
statements of private companies writing
in their report are estimates suggest
that markup growth accounted for less
than one-tenth of inflation in 2021.
underlying inflationary pressures are
proving more stubborn
the Bank of Canada declined our request
for an interview and says the report
does not represent its official view but
the Canadian Center for policy
Alternatives insists it's hard to prove
whether corporate profits are fueling
inflation who got those dollars at the
end of the day you know was it workers
through higher wages it was in fact
corporate profits it gained the largest
chunk of inflation dollars that
Canadians are paying
food is nine percent more expensive this
year than last while inflation dipped
below three percent for the first time
in two years earlier this summer High
interest rates are hurting Canadians
carrying debt and homeowners with
variable mortgages the Bank of Canada
says it is monitoring what it calls
corporate pricing Behavior as it tries
to control inflation and reach its
Target of two percent
Global News Ottawa
in BC there are fears about a dozen
properties have been destroyed by
wildfire in a popular recreational
Community Northwest of Whistler the
Downton Lake Fire was sparked by
lightning on July 13 and flared up again
late Monday more than 200 properties
around the lake got evacuation orders
yesterday the blaze is among more than
360 active wildfires across BC 15 of
them sparked in the last day
our need to garcha is inside the fire
line with members of the BC Wildfire
service she's getting an exclusive look
at one of the biggest fires burning near
a major urban center it is dangerous
work tomorrow nitu looks at how BC crews
are coping four firefighters have died
on the front lines in Canada this season
Nova Scotia RCMP believe a body they've
recovered is that of a 14 year old girl
who went missing during extreme flooding
last month
no words can describe the sympathy that
we feel for each of the families who've
been so deeply affected by the floods
although we wish the outcome was
different we're grateful that each
person could return to their close
families
the body was discovered yesterday
morning about 70 kilometers from where
the girl disappeared the province's
medical examiner is working to identify
the remains a man and two children were
also killed when two vehicles were Swept
Away by Rising flood waters 250
millimeters of rain fell in some areas
during the storm late last month
in Ukraine Russian drones have hit a
port city on the border with Romania in
a latest attempt to cut off Ukrainian
grain exports the Ismail Port is on the
Danube River it became the main transfer
point for Ukrainian grain and oil seeds
after the collapse of the Black Sea
grain deal two weeks ago since pulling
out of that agreement Russia has hit 26
Ukrainian Port facilities and destroyed
about a hundred and eighty thousand tons
of grain Crystal gemancing explains the
significance of this latest attack
Ukraine's main Inland Port seen here
from the Romanian side of the Danube
River was attacked overnight putting
another hurdle between Ukraine's grain
and its customers they went to sew to
the whole world and to soup owners that
the boards of Ukraine and the boards
offered this region are dangerous Russia
quit the U.N Black Sea grain deal July
17th it had created a humanitarian
Corridor that allowed roughly 33 million
metric tons of grain and oil seeds to be
moved out of Ukraine Rob Hubert is a
military strategist it's bleeding
remember the one of the elements of the
Russians is to bleed the enemy you you
know this is why the Russians
traditionally haven't had that much of a
concern when they're hitting civilian
targets
the Kremlin stated the attacks in the
Danube targeted facilities housing
foreign Fighters military hardware and a
Naval Shipyard Russia has been accused
in recent weeks of once again using food
as a weapon of War system
in his nightly message the Ukrainian
president said they are working to
strengthen air defense systems
units like this gephard based in the
Kiev region have been the only line of
defense against attacks on
infrastructure sites the Odessa region
has been hit numerous times in recent
weeks officials won't comment on how
many air defense units are in the area
saying only more are needed all the
poets are endangered
they could be attacked by the enemy in
the future Danube River ports like the
one in Ismail are a Lifeline in moving
Ukrainian food products to neighboring
countries and then on to customers
outside of Europe Crystal gemancing
Global News London torrential rain from
a deadly typhoon coming up the
record-shattering rainfall that flooded
Beijing
[Music]
this is the heaviest rainfall in China's
capital in 140 years
744 millimeters in the last four days
and the impact is devastating streets
turned into canals at least 21 people
are known to have died 26 others are
missing there are fears some others may
be trapped nearly 1 million people have
been forced to flee their homes and
thousands of emergency crews have been
dispatched to rescue those who are
stranded
and in Japan a typhoon slammed into the
Southwest island of Okinawa toppling
trees and flipping cars there were wind
gusts of nearly 200 kilometers an hour
and 250 millimeters of rain fell at
least one person was killed over 30
others have been hurt typhoon kanoon is
now headed west making its way towards
China's southeast coast
a remarkable story has emerged from
Brazil four men from Nigeria survived 14
days at Sea perched precariously on the
rudder of a cargo ship in June the men
stowed away on the container ship just
meters above the water hoping to reach
Europe they say they ran out of food and
water on day 10 and somehow survived by
drinking seawater when they were rescued
they were shocked to learn they traveled
5600 kilometers across the Atlantic to
Brazil
this is Brazil that was the first thing
they said this is Brazil I say wow this
is Brazil
I made it to Brazil which was a terrible
experience for me
I've been a first time I've never tried
that before
those two men have applied for asylum in
Brazil the other two have returned to
Nigeria at their own request
still ahead the Ukrainian Rabbi pushing
back against Vladimir Putin's propaganda
[Music]
since Vladimir Putin's full-scale
invasion of Ukraine the Russian
president has falsely claimed he's
liberating that country from Nazis that
rhetoric has proved particularly painful
for Ukraine's Jewish Community whose
ancestors endured the horrors of the
Holocaust Ukraine's Chief Rabbi is among
the loudest voices pushing back against
the Russian propaganda Jeff Semple
reports
on the front lines of the war in Ukraine
you might not expect to find a rabbi
dear friends now we go to say to save
people that's waiting because Moshe
Osman is Ukraine's Chief Rabbi he's
traversing the country delivering Aid
and evacuating civilians swapping his
Jewish kippa and Kittle for a helmet and
flak jacket and for good reason
on a recent trip to the flooded city of
her son a Russian shell landed nearby
fortunately no one was hurt the Russians
Russian army they shelling to the
civilian people for the evocation
missions Osman was born in Russia and
moved to Kiev 30 years ago with his
Ukrainian wife in 2015 he opened this
Refugee Center for ukrainians fleeing
the fighting in the donbass
when Russia invaded last year his
Refugee Center became a bomb shelter
that's why I was very nervous because I
helped many people as women children my
children was there and my grandchildren
small grandchildren when the bombs
finally stopped hours later Osmond
recorded this video for Facebook
speaking Russian and cradling a Torah
scroll he condemned the Russian people
the video was viewed nearly a million
times so the rabbi reported another and
another Before the War I was a very
quiet guy I cannot be now quiet his
viral videos are recorded in Russian
Ukrainian and English calling for
support from the West
Osman visited Canada this week after
earlier trips to Israel the UK and the
US meeting with Ukrainian and Jewish
Community groups that it's very
important to spread the word of Truth
and saying the Jews and the ukrainians
are together this expert in Jewish
Ukrainian relations says some in the
Jewish Community remain divided over
support for Ukraine the rabbi has very
good influence people and he can
convince and explain for Ukrainian Jews
Putin's false claim about liberating the
country from Nazis is particularly hard
to stomach
what's your reaction to that don't use
it what do you say Ukrainian the Nazis
we don't have nothing in Ukraine please
don't make speculation of the tragedy of
Jewish people now he says it's not the
Nazis but the Russians killing Jewish
people Jeff sample Global News Toronto
next how a volcanic eruption in Tonga is
contributing to Historic Heat
[Music]
a blogger in Florida got quite the shock
while filming a sewing tutorial and it
gives you lines where you can put the
trim
a car went Airborne Jen wesners was
startled then she went to help she says
the driver missed a stop sign crashed
into a drainage ditch on her front lawn
and landed just a few meters from her
house the driver was not hurt
from Canada's historic Wildfire season
to sweltering heat waves in the U.S
southern Europe and North Africa last
month was the hottest July on Earth
humans burning fossil fuels contributes
to the warming Planet but there's
evidence a massive volcanic eruption in
Tonga last year is also playing a role
in this Summer's heat Eric Sorensen
explains it was only a matter of time
for hungatanga and when the volcano blew
it blew big
an explosive plume that reached more
than 50 kilometers above the Earth much
of the eruption was beneath the ocean's
surface sending more than 40 million
tons of water vapor High into the
atmosphere the seawater magma
interaction shot everything up at very
high velocity into the atmosphere and
was one of the largest eruptions we've
ever recorded with modern
instrumentation it was the biggest
volcanic eruption since Mount Pinatubo
in the Philippines more than 30 years
ago but Pinatubo was very different
ejecting Ash that scientists believed
would have a cooling effect on the earth
those droplets will then form a haze
blocking out some of the sun's Rays
indeed when Pinatubo erupted in 1991 it
spewed sulfur dioxide gas that spread
over much of the planet the particles
deflected some of the Sun's light and
heat cooling the Earth by half a degree
over the next year now in 2022
hungatonga mostly blasted water vapor
High into the stratosphere like other
green house gases it trapped some of the
heat in our atmosphere causing a slight
warming an estimated few hundredths of a
degree hungatanga may have increased the
Earth's surface temperature this year
only slightly but however small the lead
researcher says every decimal point
counts as the planet warms those two or
three hundredths of a degree that Tonga
added
um temporarily
do matter and they do take us that
fraction closer to one and a half
degrees and and that's important because
of because of the importance of that
temperature threshold normally as from
the biggest volcanoes provide temporary
relief from the sun's intensity but with
Hunger Tonga last year it was the
opposite water vapor trapped more heat
we need to monitor each of these
volcanoes very closely because they're
all different in slight ways that have
big uh implications for the differences
in their effects on our climate volcanic
eruptions are an unavoidable part of the
natural world and compared with the
influence that humans have on climate
the impact of volcanoes is small and
temporary Eric Sorensen Global News
Toronto
and that is global national for this
Wednesday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
Euro Canada is the world's largest oil
can in brokenville Saskatchewan thanks
for watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]